So, now we're in a fancy little spot. We can create a physics engine, update
it, delete objects from it, add bodies to it, entities in the environment can
add their own physics bodies and of course update them over time. And now, we
get to the final part of the equation, how we actually drive the entire
simulation from our game engine object. This is a little bit easier than you
think. Inside of our game engine class, we first define the number of physics
updates that we want per frame. Now remember, before, we were talking about the
number of physics loops steps we would like to occur inside of a frame to move
our world forward. In the game engine's setup function, we actually need to
call an initializer on our Global Physics Engine class. And also inside of the
game engine's update function, we need to actually call the physics engine dot
update method so that it'll do a step process on all of the world objects.